hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Martin Heidegger finishes up his essay
plato's doctrine of truth by moving away
from what we might assume is its main
topic that is the allegory of the cave
and and what is going on in in education
Heidegger however has said that what the
story is also about and perhaps even
more about is a fundamental
transformation in the human
understanding and orientation to what he
calls the essence of truth and the
original essence of truth which is still
available for us but but it's concealed
is submerged is sedimented under this
entire history of Western metaphysics
and humanism as Heidegger thinks this
original conception this original
orientation this original essence of
truth views being present as the
emergence of the hidden into unhidden
as' as Heidegger says truth is a lethea
that is coming out of hiddenness coming
out of forgetfulness he also affirms
that in this originally conception of
truth is this originally essence of
truth which predates Plato and the
philosophical transformation that's
going to take place in Western culture
he says truth is a fundamental trait of
being and by that he doesn't just mean
being you know the entire range of being
as such or capital be being he means
beings each being can reveal its truth
to us or or have its truth revealed
through something else that takes it out
of hiddenness and reveals that that
places it before it makes it present to
us that Heidegger thinks has been lost
with Plato and with post Socratic
philosophy in general in the West so
what he's going to trace out in the last
really you know five six pages
this this essay is a long trajectory
leading all the way from Plato to
Nietzsche which might strike you as a
bit strange because we think of
Nietzsche is kind of an anti philosopher
he himself said that Christianity was
just platonism for the masses so you get
the idea that Platonism is a bad thing
but Heidegger regards Nietzsche as
although he's certainly going against
the history of metaphysics in many
respects as being part of that history
of metaphysics he is there at it's it's
you know going under and he's opening up
new possibilities for us which is why
Heidegger views Nietzsche as being such
a a very important philosopher but all
these other philosophers along the way
are very important as well and they all
form part of a history of metaphysics
each of them is somebody who Heidegger
will talk quite a lot about notice who
is not in there he doesn't mention Kant
who had come in between Descartes and
Nietzsche he also doesn't mention Hegel
who Heidegger holds in high regard but
also considers to be a consummate meta
physician and each of these this is a
little bit of extra background here but
I think it helps you make sense out of
what's going on here in this this piece
each of these is putting forth a novel
interpretation of the relationship
between beings and being understanding
being as one type or range of beings
that stands in for being capital B and
thereby helps us to understand beings
the entire range of what we come across
so in Plato we have a particular concept
of the form or the idea as that which
allows us to make intelligible the
material experiential objects before us
including our self and our own
reflection in Aristotle we have a
different metaphysical conception
substance is understood in a rather
different way in in relation to Plato
Aristotle in Heidegger's view represents
not only a departure from but also a
critique of and in summers
it's an improvement upon play-doh but
it's still remaining within this this
history of Western metaphysics that
Plato himself launched us into and this
has to do alta mately with an
understanding of truth as correctness
that crept in with Plato gets carried
forth in Aristotle in Aquinas we find
you know in in great medieval
scholasticism you're good to remember
that that Heidegger himself started out
studying scholastic philosophy we have
yet another conception of being now
bringing in a transcendent creator to
the mix also a distinction between
essence and existence with Descartes we
have the the beginning of the modern
project and a turn to subjectivity then
finally with Nietzsche we have what
Heidegger is going to call the
fulfillment of Western metaphysics so
what does he say about each of these in
turn
Plato we've already talked about quite a
bit he says that that you know Plato
views truth as correctness and he jokes
truth to the idea the idea or the form
is that through which we understand the
things and rightness or truth in the
mind correctness winds up being the
relation between our minds and that form
out there including the form of forms or
the form of the good the idea of the
good so he says that Plato does still
hold on a truth as a characteristic of
beings to some degree because a being
has being precisely by appearing but and
being brings unhidden us with it but it
winds up as he says being yoked to the
idea so he says when Allie theta truth
is what is named and discussed it's
really ortho taste correctness that is
meant and posited as normative and he
says this is going to set us on a path
so what we find that an Aristotle is
there's a lot going on in Aristotle but
Heidegger just brings out this he says
the the say man
beauty of the determination of the
essence of truth prevails an Aristotle
in the metaphysics towards you know the
the end of book nine says we're wrist
Italian thinking on the being of beings
reaches its peak on hiddenness is the
all-controlling fundamental train of
beings but Aristotle makes a
fundamentally important affirmation he
says in fact the true and false are not
in things themselves but in the
understanding or in the intellect in the
Neuse right so this is this is a key
idea in end da Noya in this case
actually new Scindia noia get used quite
often for intellect or understanding and
so Aristotle himself is reaffirming this
Platonic conception of truth of a
fundamentally metaphysical conception of
truth as correctness correctness of what
what's in the intellect in relation to
what's outside of the intellect or the
internal relation of the intellect to
itself with Aquinas Heidegger says he
says the Thomas Aquinas as thesis holds
good for medieval scholasticism truth is
properly encountered in the intellect
whether human or divine now he also says
you know that the truth is conceived of
as adequate co-write a an equation or
correspondence if you like or some some
sort of reckoning between the two of
them if you want to get a bit more
metaphorical notice one key element
that's been added here truth is in the
intellect whether human or divine so the
truth of things out there in the world
winds up being dependent on the fact
that they are in some respect you might
say ideas in the divine mind they are
understood in the divine intellect and
our intellect is true or our conceptions
are true the more that we approximate to
and the
very difficult of course to do so the
divine mind the more that we take on the
viewpoint that God would have of things
Descartes is going to reaffirm the same
point that Aristotle made truth is only
in the intellect and you know it's not
really doing an awful lot of work his
reference to Descartes but what what's
not being said here that I think is
worth stressing is that for Descartes we
have this turn as I said to human
subjectivity as opposed to the rest of
the world God is is in the picture for
Descartes but not in the way that he is
for Aquinas Descartes uses God to get
you know his project started and says we
don't really understand God you know at
all so I'm not going to speculate very
much about that Descartes is primarily
interested in truth as what is in the
the human mind then finally we make our
way to Nietzsche and what is Heidegger
telling us about Nietzsche remember -
Heidegger gave a very long set of
lectures on Nietzsche that take up four
volumes of his works so this is just a
very thumbnail sketch here he says in
the age when the modern era enters its
fulfillment
Nietzsche sharpens the previous thesis
still further when he says something
that is quite paradoxical here truth is
the kind of error with which a certain
kind of living being could not live in
the final analysis the value for life is
what is decisive so it seems as if
Nietzsche is adopting a sort of
pragmatism here and saying that truth is
what works for the living being but
that's not really what is is going on
here it's it's not simply reducing it to
that Nietzsche is actually asserting
that truth is a kind of error that
within truth itself there's something
fundamentally erroneous and we might
think of Nietzsche's great essay truth
and lies in an extra moral sense as
being
one of the exemplification here
Heidegger is going to quote a different
Nietzschean work the will to power but
you might read that essay if you want to
get a conception of that so he says
Nietzsche's determination of truth as in
correctness of thinking is in agreement
with the traditional essence of truth as
correctness of assertion Nietzsche's
just turning things on their head
Nietzsche is just exploiting a problem
within the system you might say he says
Nietzsche's concept of truth displays
the last glimmer of the most extreme
consequence of the change of truth from
its original essence the Auden
hiddenness of beings to the correctness
of the gaze Nietzsche remains
essentially within the Platonic
trajectory but he's just you know
reversing things and turning them on
their head so Nietzsche our Heidegger is
going to say that this is a fundamental
difference between these two conceptions
the truth it plays itself out throughout
the history of Western metaphysics but
it's still possible for us to recuperate
this original essence of of truth the
other thing that he says in here that's
particularly important is that this is
indeed metaphysics
he says Plato first appropriated of the
term philosophy is a name for the
astuteness about beings that defines the
being of beings as an idea now Plato
doesn't doesn't use the word metaphysics
Aristotle's the one who's going to coin
that but he says this is Heidegger in
fact the coining of the word metaphysics
is already pre figured in Plato's
presentation in the allegory of the cave
Plato says thinking goes met a cana
beyond those things that are experienced
merely in the form of mere shadows and
images and goes east how to out towards
those things namely the ideas so the
notion of there being a super sensuous
world something beyond the appearances
is already entering in with Plato and
continues all the way through down to
the time of Nietzsche the great opponent
of those ideas and
so the other thing that that Heidegger
is going to say here is that the
beginning of metaphysics is at the same
time the beginning of humanism and he
says here this word must be thought in
its essence we have to figure out what
does humanism actually mean so he says
in that regard humanism means a process
implicated in the beginning the
unfolding and end of metaphysics so
metaphysics and humanism go hand-in-hand
what is that process he says it's a
process whereby human beings move into a
central place among beings of course
without becoming thereby the highest
being human beings become central within
beings without thereby becoming the
highest being and in every case Plato
the forms Aristotle whatever we want to
call it substance the divine mind
something like that Aquinas definitely
God right Descartes well God also the
mind all right
Nietzsche well hard to say what exactly
is the highest for him because he's
talking about the devaluation of the
highest values but humanism is is
involved at each point and Heidegger
makes a really great point here he says
what is involved in humanism what is it
always at stake to take human beings
within the sphere of a fundamentally
metaphysically established system of
beings defined as animal rotc own ally
rational animal and to lead them to the
liberation of their possibilities the
certitude of their destiny and the
securing of their life and he gives a
number of examples about how this can
take place all of which constitute modes
of humanism so he says it could be
shaping their moral behavior the
salvation of their immortal souls
unfolding of their creative powers
development of the reason nourishing
their personalities awakening their
Civic sense cultivation of their bodies
or an appropriate combination of some or
all of these each one of them is
humanism each one is placing the human
being as central among beings and making
the human being the one for her for whom
truth exists and in whom truth can have
a place so Heidegger considers this a
mistaken perspective or set of
perspectives if you like and his goal is
ultimately to diagnose this in order to
move away from it so this history of
metaphysics that he's diagnosing here
that he's reading into Plato's allegory
of the cave is really quite important
and that is the note on which Heidegger
is going to end this essay plato's
doctrine of truth
you